اسرائيل تعود الى الواجهه هذه الايام في
الولايات المتحده عقب تلك المظاهرات
الشعبيه المستمره التي تشهدها منذ سته
اشهر ضد التعديلات القضائيه والتي هزت هزت
ثقه اركان البيت الابيض والكونغرس
والاحزاب الامريكيه فيما يسمى
بالديمقراطيه الوحيده في الشرق الاوسط هل
هناك تخوف او قلق من ان تتخلى مثلا
الاحزاب الامريكيه الديمقراطي والجمهوري
عن دعم اسرائيل هنالك مخاوف من ان يكون
هنالك شرخ قد حدث في العلاقه الاسرائيليه
مع واشنطن كما تعلم بان كل الحكومات
الاسرائيليه المتعاقبه كانت على مسافه
واحده تقريبا من الحزبين الديمقراطي
والجمهوري في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
واسرائيل لم تتدخل صراحه وعلنا حتى في
الانتخابات الامريكيه ومن هو السيد البيت
الابيض حتى لو ان العلاقات سيئه لكن يبدو
ان الحلف الامريكي الاسرائيلي ما زال
متينا ويبدو ان الاداره الامريكيه تبحث في
هذه الاثناء رب ما عن قنوات اتصال اخرى مع
الحكومه الاسرائيليه
هذا كان تحدي واضح من جانب بنيامين
نتنياهو رغم ان الرئيس بعيدا اتصل به وحثه
قبل موعد التصويت في الكنيست على ان يكون
هنالك اجماع وتوافق مع المعارضه وان يكون
هنالك اجماع كبير في الشارع الاسرائيلي
حول هذه التغييرات القضائيه
على اي شيء يراهن مبنيه مع الجانب
الامريكي مستقبل من يقول بان نتنياهو يعني
يسير قدما ويريد ان يصطدم بالحائط في
علاقاته مع الاداره
الامريكيه لكن بنيامين نتنياهو يدرك تماما
بانه لا يستطيع ان يتمادى كثيرا في هذه في
هذا التحدي الواضح والعلني مع الاداره
الامريكيه او مع الرئيس جو بايدن وما
يراهن على فوز الجمهوريين وربما عوده
ترامب الى سنه الحكم في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه الذي قدم له بالمجان الكثير
[موسيقى]
يتابعون ما يحصل في اسرائيل وبالنسبه
الكثيرين هذا ليس من موضوع المهم ولكن
لدينا انقسام
حزبين في هذا لديه مشكله حتى انه اعضاء
حزمه الديمقراطين منقسمنا بين من يؤيدوا
من يفرض شروطا على الدعم حكومه نتنياهو
ولكن هو لا يمكن ان يقوم ان يوقف هذا
التحالذي يعود الى 60 سنه مع اسرائيل
تشعرون بهذا الانقسام داخل الاحزاب الان
وينعكس على الشارع الامريكي
في مساله
ان الديمقراطيين منقسمون فيما بينهم صحيح
الى حد ما بان قدر التعلق الامر
بالجمهوريين فان اسرائيل
سواء كانت محققه مخطئه فهم يعطون كلما
اسرائيل كل ما تريده ما يصير قلق
الديمقراطيين هو انا جبان لديه تاريخي
يعود الى
1973 عندما عندما
تقع لاول مره
وهو كما قال نحن لدينا قال لنا علاقتنا
معهم كاننا اسره واحده نحن اعتقد انه يفهم
انا بالتالي فعلا هناك مجموعه شاهدنا
اثنين ثلاثه في مجلس النار الذين لم
يؤيدوا الدعم اسرائيل
[موسيقى]
انا شخصيا بين العلاقه بين الولايات
المتحده واسرائيل من جهه والعلاقه بين
القاده الامريكيين والقاده الاسرائيليين
من جهه ثانيه الولايات المتحده واسرائيل
عندها علاقات قويه جدا عمرها 75 سنه ولم
تتغير هذه العلاقات بعد مواقف معينه تكون
هنالك مواقف وخلافات بين رئيس امريكي
ورئيس حكومه اسرائيلي اما بالنسبه الى
العمق لا اعتقد انه سيحصل تغيير كبير في
العلاقه بين الولايات المتحده واسرائيل
اخليا الان انا تعتقدون ان هناك ضربه وجهه
لاسرائيل ضيقه لاسرائيل بدات تخرج عن مسار
مصالح الامريكيه عن وصعيد الدولي وهذا
يؤدي خلق حاله من الاحباط والانزعاج وكما
هو الحال في مثلا محاوله
التقليص صلاحيات المحكمه الع ليا في
اسرائيل هذا جزء من العقود العقبات
ليس بهذه السهوله تستطيع الولايات المتحده
ان تفرض بالقوه ما تريده على اسرائيل
بالروم ولو ان حليفه ولو انها حليفه
وبالرغم من المساعدات الكبرى التي تعطيها
من حبه لاسرائيل لا يستطيع ان يتدخل
مباشره ويفرض سمعنا بعض المؤيدين
ينتقدون بيضا ويقولون هذا التدخل سافر
بالشؤون الداخليه الاسرائيليه ولكن 35
مليار دولار والدعم العسكري وكل الدعم في
الامم المتحده وغير ذلك لا يعتبرون التدخل
تدخل سافرت المتحده تحاول فعلا التدخل
لذلك بهدوء اعتقد انه خلف الكواليس بايدن
يمكن ان
يعبر عن عدم رضاهي وفيما يتعلق بالمشكلتين
الرئيسيتين التي تراها الاداره الاول من
المحكمه العليا والثانيه ارتعلق
بالمستوطنات وما يحصل في الضفه الغربيه
البيت
[موسيقى]
ولكن هنالك بعض التغير الذي يحصل عندما
نعلم ان مؤسسه جالوك للاستقصاءات الراي في
شهر شباط المنصرم فبراير المنصرف وجدت ان
49% من الديمقراطيين يميلون نحو
الفلسطينيين اكثر مما يميلون نحو اسرائيل
هذا تغير كبير وهذا التغير سببه الى حد ما
الاجيال الجديده ربما بسبب ما يحصل في
اسرائيل ضد الفلسطينيين وهذه الاجيال التي
هي تتراسل مع بعضها البعض وتعلم كثيرا
مطلعه جدا بالتكنولوجيا الحديثه والاخبار
تتراسل
تنتشر بسرعه قصوى كل شيء في الخارج له
علاقه في السياسه الداخليه الامريكيه